[Music]
zeki loves to solve
logical puzzles looking at his
enthusiasm
his teacher keeps on giving him puzzles
to solve
let's look at this puzzle which was
given to zeke this time
zeki was given three boxes out of the
three
one box contained only apples another
box
only oranges and the last one contained
both
apples and oranges the first box had the
label apples
the second oranges and the third apples
and oranges
but unfortunately all the boxes were
mislabeled
so the task given to zeki was to fix
this
such that each box had the correct labor
this doesn't even seem like a puzzle
does it hold on
it's not as easy as it seems zeki was
given a few conditions that he needed to
comply with
the first condition stated that he could
not look inside the boxes
moreover he could ask for only one
random fruit from any of the boxes at a
time
and with this help he needed to
correctly label the boxes
zeki would be tested on this factor
number of boxes he opened to solve this
puzzle
that is he had to do this by opening a
minimum number of boxes
what do you think was our smart zeki
able to crack it
yes he was zeki did solve the puzzle
and also impressed the teacher but how
did he solve it
why don't you pause the video and try
solving it yourself
hey this is ganesh here from don't
memorize before we get to the solution
of this riddle
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and hit the bell icon
so that you never miss a video from us
okay back to where we left off
well let's understand the strategies
that led zeki to the answer
zeki takes a piece of paper and a pen
and jots down the plausible scenarios
ok he starts with the first box which
has the label apples on it
as it's mislabeled zeki knows that this
box will definitely not have
only apples in it it can either have
only oranges
or apples and oranges now
if zeki points out this box and the
random fruit drawn is an apple
then it becomes obvious that this box
would contain
apples and oranges does by elimination
we can conclude that the box named
oranges would have
apples as it cannot have oranges in it
while the one with the label apples and
oranges
would have oranges bingo
in just one attempt zeki could find out
the fruits present in the boxes
thus labeling the boxes correctly
this was easy isn't it but wait before
you can jump to any conclusion
we need to look at the other side of the
coin too
now what if instead of an apple it's an
orange which is drawn
then will the situation remain the same
nope
it will be a scene of uncertainty let's
see how
if it's an orange that's drawn from the
first box then it would mean
that the box could contain either only
oranges or both
apples and oranges zeki makes a table
like this
considering both the possibilities but
he immediately strikes off these two
possibilities
as in this case the last box cannot have
both
apples and oranges and in this case the
second box cannot have only oranges
and why so that's because the boxes are
mislabeled
zeki could see that both these scenarios
were possible
hence to ascertain what's there in this
first box
he had to open the second box too
so if zeki decides to open box two and
orange is the random fruit
then he has successfully solved the
puzzle
and how can he be so sure about it with
the help of the table
zeki can be very sure that the third box
will have
only apples zeki needed two attempts to
label the boxes correctly
but the problem doesn't seem to end here
zeki again takes a look at the table he
had constructed
now the problem erupts if instead of an
orange it's an apple that is drawn from
box two
in this case from the table zeki knows
that there could be two possibilities
box two might contain either only apples
or both
apples and oranges to confirm what's
there in boxes one and two
he will have to open the third box too
so how many attempts that's correct
three attempts
so what can we deduce from this the
number of attempts are totally dependent
on the random fruit that's removed from
the box
luck by chance zeki is not satisfied
with this answer
he tries to apply yet another strategy
here he thinks that what if after
opening box 1
he directly opens box 3. let's see the
results obtained
here zeki observes that if an orange is
removed from box 1
and then instead of box 2 if he asks for
a random fruit from box 3
he has a definite combination in just
two attempts
similarly even if apple is the random
fruit drawn from box one
zeki gets a definite combination so from
three attempts which are purely based on
luck
zeki is down to two definitive attempts
now what if
instead of box one zeki decides to open
box two
which has been mislabeled as orange
well it would be similar to the
possibilities obtained
when a random fruit was drawn from box
one
here's the table that seki constructed
for your reference
zeki now thinks whatever random fruit is
removed directly from box three
could this be the answer time to check
now imagine the random fruit removed
from this box is an
apple as it's removed from the
mislabeled box of apples and oranges
zeki is sure that this box would contain
only apples
he now moves to the next box with the
label oranges
remember the boxes are labeled wrong
hence
by elimination zeki could conclude that
this box would contain
oranges and apples which means the final
box
box one could have only one possible
fruit
and that is oranges wow
just by drawing one sample from box
three zeke could solve the entire puzzle
now you may debate what if instead of an
apple it was an orange that was removed
from the box
even if seki gets an orange it would
take zeki just one attempt to solve this
riddle
applying the same logic as before so
here
luck had no role to play it was pure
logic
whichever fruit is removed the number of
attempts remain the same
that is he just has to draw one random
fruit from the last box
after going through all the
possibilities it's clear that removing a
random fruit from the third box
is the key to this puzzle and this is
how in one attempt
zeki could crack the puzzle now before
signing off
let me shoot yet another puzzler tier
but remember
this one may or may not follow the logic
which zeki had used to solve this puzzle
a thief tells the truth on monday
wednesday
and friday and he lies on the other days
one day the thief said i will tell the
truth tomorrow
so on which day did the thief say this
leave your answers in the comments
section
and for more interesting riddles and
puzzles stay tuned to our channel